bekanntlich ist ja kein
dennoch ist sie in diesen tagen
allgegenwärtig die angst vor dem krieg
vor dem virus und dann auch noch die
angst vor der inflation
und sie ist längst da die inflation
getrieben von putin und der pandemie
aber eben auch von eigenen hausgemachten
effekten wie bedrohlich ist die lage wie
irrational ist die deutsche angst vor
einer inflation was treibt sie und was
kann man wie kann man ihr begegnet
mit diesen fragen begrüße ich sie ganz
herzlich war unter den linden
und ich begrüße hier bei mir sehr hat
sich michael caine an den staatssekretär
im bundeswirtschaftsministerium
für wirtschafts für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz ist nämlich ein bisschen
verändert worden deswegen habe ich jetzt
gerade mal ins stottern von bündnis 90
und die grünen kommt man sie und ich
begrüße sehr herzlich professor hans
werner sinn wirtschaftswissenschaftler
und ehemaliger präsident des
ifo-instituts herzlich willkommen an sie
weil er keiner die inflationsrate im
januar
beträgt 49 5 prozent so ist es beziffert
worden nachdem das statistische
bundesamt für das jahr 2021
die inflationsrate auf 3,1 prozent
verkündet hat das war der höchste wert
seit fast 30 jahren macht sie das als
staatssekretär im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium
nachdenklich ja das ist eine zahl die
man sich sehr genau anschauen müssen wir
auch guckt wie geht das weiter und wir
haben ja ein das haben sie ja gerade in
dem anfangs stück ja schon gesagt wir
haben sicherlich ein paar effekte die
sonderfaktoren aus dem letzten jahr sind
wie die reduzierung der mehrwertsteuer
die einmalige oder die
co2 bepreisung diese sonderfaktoren
treten dieses jahr nicht mehr auf
deswegen gehe ich davon aus dass
ungefähr so ein basiseffekt von 1 5 bis
zwei prozentpunkten da drin sind das ist
das erklärt sagen teil deswegen glaube
ich auch wird die inflation ein stück
zurückgehen aber wir sehen auch
einerseits durch durch die
preisträger auch durch lieferengpässe
und natürlich durch die wahnsinn gezogen
habe von den kosten für fossile energie
wir reden ja vielleicht mal für die
auswahl situation und die ukraine und
russland haben wir da eine wahnsinnige
kostenexplosion gesehen die
die inflation treibt das wir sehen das
ja eine braune inflation durch diese
fossilen energie preisen macht sie das
auch ein stück weit nachdenklich in
hinblick auf die
modernisierungsprojekte wie die ampel
vor hat sind die dadurch gefährdet und
dass wir die das vorankommen müssen mit
der modernisierung der wirtschaft mit
dem klimaschutz da wird dass es eine
ganz klare aufgabe nur die
rahmenbedingung man sich die aufgabe
nicht kleiner sondern größer habe wir
sind das sehr entschieden sie anzugehen
und ehrlich gesagt wenn ich mir anschaue
ein teil der inflation ist ja dadurch
getrieben dass wir so abhängig sind von
fossiler von braun energie gas kohle und
je schneller wir auf erneuerbare
umsteigen auf grüne energien hat das
einen dämpfenden faktor das heißt es ist
sowieso sagen es erhöht die noch mal
mehr die dringlichkeit für für eine
energiewende und für klimaschutz
wenn es um die bewertung der
inflationären tendenzen geht entscheiden
sich ja so ein bisschen die die
politischen oder die
wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen geister in
deutschland sie prognostizieren eine
länger anhaltende inflation eine
inflations phase die länger andauert und
plädieren dafür das feuer rechtzeitig
auszutreten worin sehen sie denn die
indikatoren für eine längere
inflationsphase
das licht in selbst verstärkung effekten
es ist schon so dass wir jetzt anstoßen
effekte haben für die sich hier zeigen
in der inflation die auch wieder vorüber
gehen insofern kann man schon sagen das
ist also ein hucal nur der huckel führt
nicht zurück auf das ausgangsniveau
sondern indem hucal sind schon wieder
neue inflationseffekte angelegt
insbesondere die lohn preis spirale da
kommt man später sehen wir haben jetzt
verbraucherpreise die sind um 5,4
prozent genau höher als im durchschnitt
des jahres 2020 der tat sich noch nicht
viel und das jetzige niveau ist einfach
5,4 prozent genau höher und die
gewerkschaften werden natürlich sagen
das wollen wir haben bei den nächsten
lohnverhandlungen zu recht nicht nur dem
produktivitätszuwachs sondern auch diese
inflation und das bedeutet dann schon
wieder inflation für das jahr 2023 da
ist dann die nächste welle schon wieder
angelegt wir haben das in den 70er
jahren gesehen als wir auch
ölpreissteigerungen hatten und inflation
da dauerte das ein ganzes jahr bis aus
dem ersten huggel und der zweite
geworden war und die gewerkschaften
tatsächlich zugelangt haben um das zu
kompensieren für ihre leute das ist
verständlich vielleicht noch ein thema
die
grüne inflation oder die braune
inflation also für die für die grünen
ist das eine braune inflation aber ich
weiß nicht ob das so richtig ist die
hauptsache ist doch nicht die energie
preissteigerung die hauptsache er hat
mit dem lockdown zu tun weltweit haben
wir verknappungen die häfen chinas sind
zu wägen quarantänemaßnahmen die schiffe
staunt sich es fehlt an vorprodukten in
deutschland die chips fehlen es fehlt
aluminium magnesium alles mögliche und
die firmen des verarbeitenden gewerbes
klagen darüber dass sie keine
vorprodukte kriegen und gleichzeitig hat
der staat in der korona krise
letztlich mit dem geld das die
notenbanken eben gegeben haben
diese ganzen rettungsprogramme gemacht
ob zu recht oder nicht ist dass wir mal
dahingestellt aber das ist jedenfalls
nachfrage für die keine güter da sind
also angebotsseitig wurde beschränkt
durch die lock down in deutschland und
weltweit und gleichzeitig hat man
schulden dampf sozusagen in das system
eingegeben und das schaffte ein
nachfrageüberhang und das ist der
haupttreiber der inflation wir haben 60
prozent
bis zu 80 prozent der firmen im
verarbeitenden gewerbe die bei den
umfragen sich darüber beklagen dass sie
nicht genug vorprodukte kriegen also man
nennt das in der ökonomischen theorie
stagnation wenn ich es an nachfrage
fehlt sondern wenn die firmen gar nicht
in der lage sind die nachfrage zu
befriedigen das ist die grundsituation
in der wir sind das hat am rande mit der
inflation zu tun und sie ist nicht nur
braun sie ist auch ziemlich grün weil
die strompreise in deutschland sehr sehr
hoch sind mit 36 cent pro kilowattstunde
und die sind deswegen so hoch weil wir
die grüne energiearten denn die grüne
energie aus wind und sonne verlangt ja
komplementär den konventionellen strom
um die dunkel flauten zu füllen das geht
ja gar nicht alleine ohne und diese
doppelstrukturen dass wir die alten noch
brauchen für die dunkelsten und jetzt
die grüne energie dazu haben bedeutet
eben doppeltes geld und hat dazu geführt
dass für die höchsten stromkosten auf
der ganzen welt haben um bei
inselstaaten vielleicht abgesehen aber
unter den nennenswerten staaten der welt
wir haben das schlagwort gerade gehört
grüne inflation wie stehen sie dazu dass
wir sind ja hier in einem gepflegten
streitgespräch dass sich tatsächlich
anders wenn man sich anschaut also
erneuerbare energien sind heute in den
steuerungs kosten viel preiswerter sie
kriegen heute für fünf bis sechs cent pv
freiflächenanlagen die zuschläge wenn
viel wind weht sind die strompreise an
den börsen entsprechend niedrig diese
effekte sehen will ja und was wir sehen
wir haben eine explosion und zwar
übrigens nicht nur in deutschland
sondern einem globalen maßstab der fas
ihre energiepreise bei gas bei kohle
deswegen steigen ja auch die die kosten
dafür und sie wissen ja auch dass
sowie das mag design ist dann immer der
der letzte anbieter sozusagen dem fall
gas dann die kosten bestimmt und mich
nicht die erneuerbaren und da sehen wir
eine große kostenexplosion wir sehen
übrigens auch getrieben durch
woraus dann erfüllt gerade mal seine
langfristigen
lieferverpflichtungen aber eben auch
nicht mehr man könnte ja denken wenn
jetzt die preise groß sind würde mehr
verkauft die pipelines sind da ist wäre
viel viel platz für zusätzliche rungen
erfolgen aus anderen gründen nicht das
treibt die energiekosten das treibt die
preise und wenn wir uns anschauen das
ist ein verhältnisse 1 cent ist die co2
verpressung 19 sind die gestiegenen
gaspreise also eins zu zehn mal um diese
größenordnungen klarzumachen über die
wir reden uns wo da die punkte sind und
wissen sie ich war jetzt gerade die
woche viel wieder in brandenburg
unterwegs letzte woche und wird wird
halt nach wie vor teure russisches
erdgas verfeuert anstatt anstatt
windstrom zu nutzen den es übrigens gut
als wärmespeicher verwenden können dafür
schaffen wir jetzt die voraussetzung um
eben auch eine dekarbonisierung von
wärme wir so schön heiß zu erreichen
also da da wollen wir den schalter
umlegen das wirkt dann auch dagegen und
ja sie haben an einer stelle war
ausdrücklich recht das will ich
unterstreichen dass bei der lieferketten
das ist eine problematik wir haben
bestimmte lieferketten durch krone wir
haben die die sehenden vor produkte im
bereich halbleiter chips ist es
sicherlich dass gerade bekannteste
beispiel aber ja nicht nur ich gehe
davon aus dass wir auch da im zuge
dieses jahres normalisierung erreichen
werden auch das wirkt dann hoffentlich
dämpfend auf die inflation dass das
hängt natürlich auch davon ab wie es mit
corona wie es mit auch omikron in den
nächsten monaten weitergeht aber auch da
könnte es oder so sind zumindest die
anzeichen einer entspannung gebe es
klagen und zumindest im vergleich zum
letzten jahr jetzt anfang des jahres
weniger für das klagen noch genügend
firmen über aber weniger firmen über
lieferengpässe liefern mangel so dass
ich hoffe dass es da eine entspannung
gibt was dann
auch entsprechende auswirkungen hätte
ich würde mal gerne zurückkommen auf die
energiepreise würden sie sagen herr
professor sinn dass die energiewende die
bürger und auch die wirtschaft jetzt
endlich überfordert
zumindest so wie sie angepackt wird und
das wird man sehen nicht also wir haben
ja vor
in 23 jahren was sind schon 23 jahre
vollkommen auszusteigen aus sämtlichen
konventionellen energieträgern
kernkraft wird ja dieses jahr
abgeschaltet und kohle soll sehr rasch
abgeschaltet werden die autos sollen
nicht mehr mit
mit benzin fahren
und perspektivisch soll ja dann das gas
auch wieder verschwinden bis 2045 nicht
da habe ich doch meine zweifel ob also
solche historischen umwälzungen
innerhalb von 23 jahren gelingen könnten
das kommt mir ehrlich gesagt topisch vor
und ich glaube auch nicht dass es
irgendwie gelingen kann und deswegen
auch nicht ganz vernünftig ist einen
solchen weg einzuschlagen von dem man
sagen wird nachher das ist gar nicht
realistisch war das zu tun also das ist
ein schwieriges thema klima problem
haben wir soll man nicht kleinen leugnen
kleinreden aber
was wir uns da vorgenommen haben ist
dann doch sehr sehr energisch und das
wird auf jeden fall dazu dass die preise
die irgendwie mit energie zu tun haben
dann sehr teuer werden und ich möchte
noch mal darauf zurückkommen sie haben
gesagt der sonnenstrom sei so willig und
der windstrom das ist richtig und falsch
es ist richtig wenn sie kilowattstunde
gleich kilowattstunde rechnen aber das
kann man nicht so rechnen denn der strom
muss ja nach der verfügbarkeit berechnet
werden nicht zu jedem zeitpunkt braucht
man den strom wieder geliefert wird und
die grünen quellen liefern halt und
haben ein speise privileg und kommen
dann ins netz rein wenn sie wollen und
nicht wenn die verbraucher es wollen das
ist der unterschied zu konventioneller
energie die kann ich regeln auf und
runter
ich brauche halt für den grünen strom
zwingend und das ist ein teil element
des grünen stroms die regelbare energie
die das kompliment ist wenn der grüne
strom rauf geht geht die runter und
umgekehrt so dass der verbrauch erfüllte
zwingend man kann also nicht das trennen
und sagen das sind die kosten des grün
und das sind die anderen die braunen
kosten die brauchen kosten sind zwingend
mit dem grünen strom verbunden und wenn
es nicht wenn sie nicht braun sind
müssen es atomstrom sein und da streiten
sich die geister ob der grünen ist oder
nicht die franzosen die meisten europäer
die eu kommission sagt er ist grün also
wir brauchen irgendwie so wird so etwas
und die kosten müssen dem grünen strom
zu gerechnet werden und der deutsche weg
ist halt mit doppelten strukturen
fixkosten verbunden die grünen kosten
bringen fixkosten und die alten kosten
bringen auch fixkosten und die müssen
beide getragen werden und das erklärt
warum deutschland ich wiederhole es
weltmeister bei den stromkosten ist da
machen wir natürlich die nicht nur die
bevölkerung arm damit sondern auch die
industrie kaputt wenn wir diesen kurs
fortsetzen würden es muss man sich
überlegen wie man das weg bringt die
regierung hat ja schon beschlossen dass
jetzt aus dem einkommensteuertarif und
anderen heraus die stromkosten
finanziert werden sollen aber das ist ja
nur eine ein versteckspiel die bürger
müssen es ja trotzdem irgendwie zahlt ja
keiner sie sagten gerade wir in
brandenburg unterwegs gewesen ich nehme
an sie waren da vielleicht auch bei dem
ein oder andere mittelständler sind hier
auch für den mittelstand zuständig
inwiefern gibt es darin beschwerden über
die hohen energiekosten sind es grad vor
allem die handel völker die sich über
die steigenden kosten beschweren oder
wer ist das der sich da beschwert und
wie hart trifft es die mittelständler
alles ist ganz hart so dass viele der
besonders energieintensiven unternehmen
die sind der beispielsweise vom eeg
schon bereits ausgenommen oder haben
sonderregel die triftern der der
steigende börsen stromkreis aber gerade
für jetzt den bäckermeister der sein
projekt in seiner stube anhalt sondern
der ist natürlich von den ansteigenden
energiekosten besonders betroffen und
jetzt sehen wir dass ein punkt den ich
zum beispiel richtig und wichtig finde
ist dass wir in unternehmen selber
grünen strom erzeugen dass sie den auch
sehr preisgünstig für sich verwenden
können weil es ist eben noch mal anders
sie können natürlich auch grünstrom gut
speichern sie haben heute probleme die
das verhindern also sie können strom in
wärme gut speichern wenn sie in kavernen
wasser ja wie eine thermoskanne können
sie dort wärme gut speichern wie können
sie verwenden wenn sie es brauchen und
es ist allemal besser das so zu machen
als weiteres gas zu kaufen dann sind sie
ist viel viel preiswerter und viel
günstiger das ist ein punkt aber dann
für den handwerksmeister wenn er sich
eine photovoltaikanlage aufs dach liegt
oder sich an einem windrad beteiligt
dass er diesen strom den er selbst
erzeugt auch zu den selbstkostenpreis
nutzen kann auch das gar kein anderer
zahlen um sowohl die energiewende voran
zu bekommen als auch den die
stromrechnung wieder nach unten zu
bekommen und ein punkt den wir deutlich
im oder klar auch im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben ist die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage
weil das ist ja ein punkt nicht wenn ich
jetzt wieder beim bäcker bleibe die
zahlt er anders als war ich die
aluminiumhütte und zahlte die das heißt
wer profitiert davon wenn die liebe oder
aber durch den mittelstand da
tatsächlich umzusteigen denn das ist ja
noch mal mit höheren investitionen auch
verbunden der mittelstand nicht
unbedingt
dieses geld zur verfügung hat und das
ist unterschiedlich auch zwischen ost
und westdeutschland sehr unterschiedlich
weil auch die kapitalausstattung jetzt
von unternehmen in ostdeutschland einmal
deutlich geringer ist im durchschnitt
als als in westdeutschland deswegen gibt
es ja auch von seiten der
bundesregierung auch zum teil von den
ländern natürlich unterstützung und
und fördermaßnahmen aber ansich erlebe
ich ihn auch dass mir ganz viele sagen
ja dass das ist eine dieser erneuerbare
energien ist ein wahnsinns
konjunkturprogramm weil irgendwann muss
die anlagen installieren da muss sie
warten und ehrlich gesagt was wir wo wir
reinlaufen ist ein großer
fachkräftemangel also das ist jetzt
schon das ist übrigens auch ja ich
bleibe aber bei den beispielen können
auch gerne die bundesländer wechseln
aber es ist auch selbst in der
strukturschwachen wunderschön regionen
wie im nordosten brandenburgs der fall
wo wirst schon sehen dass wirklich ein
arbeitskräftemangel in vielen bereichen
haben und das ist ein punkt den wir
dringend angehen müssen wir auch mehr
qualifizierung brauchen wir mehr
einwanderung brauchen und wo ich aber
auch erlebe das ist viele menschen sagen
mannschaft richtig jobs auch für die
zukunft wir brauchen nicht wirklich ein
konjunkturprogramm denn die wirtschaft
ist ja total überhitzt etwa die
inflation nicht wir haben doch sehr sehr
viel staatsschulden gehabt in der
vergangenheit und das ist nachfrage der
staat nimmt niemandem steuern weg
sondern scheinbar kommt das geld vom
lieben gott und gibt das aus und dann
kriegen die leute das und können das
ausgeben für ihre konsum wieder käufer
oder der stadt gibt es auch direkt aus
in dem auto bauen lässt oder so etwas
ist also nachfrage in hülle und fülle da
viel zu viel für das kleine angebot
fachkräftemangel heißt ja dass das
angebot zu klein ist verschuldung heißt
dass die nachfrage groß ist in diesen
überhang zu vergrößern in dem man
konjunktur programme macht es falsch
also konjunkturprogramm das ja gleich
bedeutend mit staatsverschuldung und
verausgabung von mitteln und das
brauchen wir nicht ist alle alle diese
schönen träume die man in der
vergangenheit gehabt hat über
verschuldung dieses oder jenes oder
selbiges zu finanzieren zerplatzen im
moment an der inflationären möglichkeit
das sind argumente von gestern wir sind
heute in einer inflationären zeit wo das
alles nicht mehr zulässig ist sondern
müssen uns einschränken in der nachfrage
damit es nicht zu noch mehr inflation
kommt dass sich tatsächlich anders aber
deswegen sitzen wir hier auch der in der
einladungs kombination sicherlich das ja
auch gar nicht schlimm sondern wir sehen
ja wie man oder zum teil die
infrastruktur ist denn jetzt will ich
mal als grüner ein beispiel die
autobahnbrücken die vom zerfall bedroht
die möchte ich nicht dass sie zusammen
da sind wir uns eigentlich so da ist
wird
damit so schulden ja nein und zum teil
auch eben über schulden weil wenn ich
sehe was wir was für künftigen
generationen hinterlassen wenn wir diese
klimakrise nicht anpacken wenn wir nicht
auch da investieren dass wir zum
beispiel grün stahl herstellen oder das
wird in erneuerbare energien ausbauen
und alles schon so gemeinsames vorher
nebensatz gesagt ich fand er sehr
richtig dass wir wir haben corona die
unternehmen unterstützt haben die dann
waren sie die umsatzrückgänge haben und
dort sehr viel dafür getan haben dass
das unternehmen und arbeitsplätze
erhalten werden das ist genau so richtig
so wie ich sehe dass wir gerade in
regionen die von einem strukturwandel
betroffen sind dort auch unternehmen
helfen gerade dort wo die kapitaldecke
kleiner und dünner ist und das finde ich
ist total richtig ich weiß nicht ob ich
sie da anders verstanden habe aber da
finde ich es richtig dass wir eine
entsprechende förderung und
unterstützung auch für eine
transformation verhandeln
weil sie mich verstanden haben wir jetzt
wahrscheinlich dass auch natürlich hat
der staat wichtige aufgaben zu erfüllen
im bereich der infrastruktur die ja
finanzieren muss die frage ist nur wie
es gibt ja mehrere es gibt im prinzip
drei wege erstens reduziert andere
ausgaben zweitens nimmt den leuten
steuergeld weg und drittens er macht das
über verschuldung und dieser dritte weg
führt zu inflation und das geht eben
nicht mehr das ist das problem man kann
nicht mal fünf prozent inflation sagen
wir wollen jetzt weil wir schöne zwecke
haben noch mehr schulden finanzieren man
muss jetzt ehrlich seinen bürgern sagen
ihr müsst euch entscheiden wir haben zu
wenig menschen die arbeiten können
facharbeitermangel sowieso demokratische
verwerfung sowieso wir können nicht
alles wir haben die ressourcen die wir
müssen jetzt prioritäten setzen ob wir
über konsumgüter oder lieber
infrastruktur güter in deutschland
wollen unterstrich vieles verletzte
konnte dann ist tatsächlich hoch in
deutschland ich hätte gern noch mal zur
energiewende zurückkommen dahingehend
inwiefern schlechter liebe energiewende
die deutsche wettbewerbsfähigkeit
naja also die deutschen firmen die
intensive energie intensiv arbeiten
denken sie nur mal an die
aluminiumindustrie oder die wafer
industrie die haare schwierigkeiten
wacker chemie in bayern ist einer der
größten stromverbraucher und so das land
ist ein ganz deutschland ja die haben
ein werk in tennessee in amerika
errichtet weil sie dort
den strom für weniger als 10 us cent
bekommen und das für 30 jahre garantiert
also das führt dann automatisch zu einer
verlagerung der industrien und kostet
uns lebensstandard wenn wir das machen
das wäre nicht so
würde diese grüne politik in amerika
auch betrieben ja wenn man das weltweit
macht ist das ein ganz anderes thema
aber wenn man das alleine macht mehr
oder weniger und anderen machen nicht
mit dann hat man hier ein problem und
dieses problem ist eigentlich das
hauptproblem bei der grünen politik
grüne politik ja aber kann man sie
unilateral machen als einzelnes land
oder auch als ländergruppe wie die eu
wenn der rest der welt nicht wirklich
mitmacht in pariser abkommen haben wir
zwar 200 unterschriften fast aber 60
unterschriften sind nur von ländern die
sich zu irgendwas konkret verpflichtet
haben und 140 unterschriften sind von
ländern die applaudieren dass die 60
sich verpflichtet haben einzuschränken
das kann ja nicht die lösung sein wenn
die sich jetzt zum beispiel
beschließen durch energische
umweltpolitische was haben dass sie
weniger
brennstoffe kaufen öl oder gas auf den
weltmärkten dann ist es ja nicht so dass
das co2 nicht mehr in die luft kommt
denn die brennstoffe sind ja da die
müssten wir ja kaufen und in europa in
silos irgendwie versiegeln dass da
keiner ran kommt aber das tun wir ja
nichts wir ja auch absurd wir lassen sie
auf den weltmärkten und zu fallenden
preisen werden diese stoffe an andere
länder verkauft wie kaufen die
finanzieren ihren co2 intensiven
aufschwung damit und es kommt genauso
viel co2 in die luft wie vorher und die
deutsche industrie und die europäische
wird malträtiert das ist halt das
ergebnis wir uns nicht koordinieren man
kann mit den anderen ländern also es ist
essenziell dass wir hier bindende
vereinbarung krieg mit den anderen
ländern und die amerikaner die haben
zwar unterschrieben beim pariser
abkommen job ist dann ausgestiegen
beiden ist wieder eingestiegen aber weil
es ganz still geworden bei diesem thema
und im letzten sommer hat dann noch die
saudis angewiesen kann man fast sagen
mehr öl zu produzieren also ganz ehrlich
meint er das gar nicht mit dieser
beteiligung an den grünen projekt immer
so ein bisschen bei diesen unilateralen
ausstieg oder bei der energiewende die
deutschland ja vor allen dingen
vorantreibt ein stück weit bleiben
inwiefern haben sie denn dancer bekommen
durch die entscheidung der eu kommission
jetzt gas und auch die kernenergie als
nachhaltig einzustufen inwiefern ist das
für sie ein problem das haben wir uns
hätten wir nicht gebraucht und nicht
gewünscht aber ich würde gern noch mal
kurz auf die argumente eingehen der
schlag war ich halte sie logischerweise
für überzeugen sie mich nicht aber
deswegen nicht deswegen reden wir ja
auch das finde ich auch eine ist ja
einen genauen wert auch unterschiedliche
argumente ging es nichts zu halten also
erstens natürlich haben wir die
europäische union das ist ja gerade
darauf gemeinsam auch mit der frage wie
kann man zu sagen mit den grands
ausgleich co2 kosten an der grenze
handelt das komme jetzt schwierige
fragen von handelspolitik rein aber ich
will noch mal eins sagen wir sehen doch
gerade das fossile energien massiv
teurer werden und zwar auf den auf dem
weltmarkt ist ja mitnichten so wir sehen
dass europa das deutschland anstrengung
unternimmt die pariser klimaziele zu
erreichen das ist auch total wichtig für
für alle und ich sehe eine große chance
was machen ja gerade die investieren
massiv gerade in die frage von grünem
wasserstoff und wasserstofftechnologie
wohlwissend wohl wissen dass wir auch
wahrscheinlich in der zukunft teile des
grünen wasserstoff sowie die heute
nach deutschland importieren
wahrscheinlich auch teile von grünen
wasserstoff in deutschland herrscht eine
andere teile auch importieren werden
also zeigen
treibhausgas neutrales gast co2 frei
müsse aus erneuerbaren energien gewinnen
und trotzdem ist es ein riesiges
geschäftsfeld auch für deutschland für
maschinenbau für ingenieurswesen diese
produktionskette die lagerung die
produktion die die herstellung das zu
beherrschen da werden wir eine
vorreiterposition haben und werden durch
eine unglaublich starke rolle haben eben
durch diesen massiven ausbau dieser
erneuerbare energien also ich würde
sagen dass ich eine große chance für den
standort drin das kann man auch sie
haben es gerne anders rum beschrieben
ich würde sagen wir haben steigende co2
haben steigen der frostige
energiepreise das sehen wir ja gerade
bei bei öl und gas das kann man ja an
der tankstelle gerade jeden tag sehen
und deswegen ist diese frage von
dekarbonisierung sowohl klimapolitisch
geboten ist aber auch dieses
wirtschaftspolitisch richtig und darum
geht glaube ich ein streit und damit
wollte ich ja überhaupt nicht diese
frage nach der taxonomie
ausweiten ausreichendes gab diesen
ergänzt aktion hat man ja auch deutlich
gehört dass wir
nicht fanden dass es dafür eine diese
taxen regelung brauchte das ja dass aus
unseren bedarf hätten wir gerne darauf
verzichtet zu den steigenden preisen ja
das geht kurzfristig jetzt sehr hoch
es war aber auch untergegangen vor zwei
jahren vor wenigen jahren 45 jahren
hatten wir einen ölpreis von 140 dollar
pro barrel und jetzt legen wir bei 100
in der größenordnung also es geht immer
rauf und runter wir haben insgesamt
energiepreise die sind wenn man die
inflationsbereinigt nicht höher als bei
der zweiten ölkrise 1980 82 wir sind
also es ist erstaunlich wie wenig die
fossilen energiepreise gestiegen sind es
ist also auch nicht richtig eignen der
preis für eine sache ist halt massiv
gefallen also anschaut was in den
letzten 20 jahren erreicht wir müssen
jetzt natürlich da wahnsinnig zulegen
aber wenn man sich mal anschaut dann ist
natürlich da ein großer gewinn für
erneuerbare und das natürlich
wir sehen nach saudi arabien stücke dann
lieber die erneuerbaren sollte hat nicht
mehr wertschöpfung erreicht als dass
oder röcke kürzer andere regime suchen
für die wir wahrscheinlich ähnlich viel
sympathie hegen deswegen genau ich bin
grundsätzlich war also das spricht viel
dafür nur die frage ist wie kommen wir
da hin bedarf es der politik die hier
mit hilft durch subventionen vor allem
durch verbote von konventioneller
energie oder können wir das dem markt
überlassen denn wenn die erneuerbaren so
viel billiger sind als die anderen dann
braucht es doch keine förderung durch
den staat dann setzen die sich davon
alleine durch aber diese förderung hört
ja nicht auf sie ist jetzt macht das
alles doch auch im vergleich sehr teuer
es wäre glaube ich wirklich besser das
weltweit zu machen alles was die politik
anordnen muss weil es nicht von alleine
passiert ist qua definitionem schon
teurer also das argument wir machen
jetzt grünen energie und steigern dann
auch noch unseren lebensstandard halte
ich für nicht überzeugend wir machen
grüne energie opfern einen teil unseres
materielle lebensstandards um das klima
den klimawandel zu verlangsamen das ist
eine saubere argumentation aber
natürlich müssen wir an zukünftige
generationen denken wir haben ein
klimaproblem die welt muss was dagegen
tun aber das argument das kaufe ich hebe
nicht ab dass man sagt wir haben jetzt
zwei fliegen die wir mit einer klappe
schlagen wir tun was gutes für das klima
und erhöhen auch noch unseren
lebensstandard erhöhen die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit weil der staat
bestimmte energieformen verbietet das
ist nicht der fall das wasser wenn er da
eingreifen muss indem wir verbietet zum
beispiel bei den verbrennungsmotoren ja
faktisch verboten sind in perspektivisch
dann macht er die sache natürlich teurer
weil wenn er nicht eingreifen würde und
es wäre billiger würde es ja von alleine
passiert das passiert aber nicht schon
allein ist passiert nur durch den
eingriff des staates und dann ist es
automatisch teurer herr keller da so ein
bisschen noch mal moderieren würde
freiheit und opfern nichts aber egal ich
würde würde auch er hatte noch mal so
ein bisschen auf den einzelnen
hinterkopf wie opfern nur materiellen
lebensstandard für die umwelt freiheit
für die qualität unserer
würde gerne nochmal so auch den
einzelnen der ja die an der tankstelle
wenn er an der ölheizung hat oder sonst
wo die hohen energiepreise besonders
spürt wenn die heizkostenabrechnung
kommen die nächste dann wird er das noch
mal besonders spüren inwiefern muster
einer entlastung stattfinden frau
gallwitz hat jetzt eine angekündigt aber
viele sagen natürlich dass die nicht in
einem vernetzten ausreicht ja also dass
wir dass wir da was tun müssen dass er
erstens hat die koalition den
heizkostenzuschuss beschlossen es geht
ja auch die frage zuschlag für kinder
bei regelsätzen
um da auch ein ausgleich zu schaffen ich
sprach vorhin schon über die die
abschaffung der eeg umlage oder andere
finanzierung der eeg-umlage was ihm
familien was kleinunternehmen hilft und
macht es das finde ich das finde ich
richtig
das hat die koalition sich ja auch
vorgenommen und das das sollten wir auch
tun und da ist mir eine zielgerichtete
soziale unterstützung von menschen die
das besonders brauchen ist da dass das
richtige instrument deswegen diese
fragen heizkostenzuschuss deswegen
dieser punkt mit dem kinderzuschlag oder
noch einen zuschlag für hartz4 empfänger
und dann wieder sehr vereinbart ist die
absenkung die abschaffung der eeg-umlage
das hilft dann kann man generell sagen
herr professor sinn dass die inflation
sozial schwächere sehr viel stärker
trifft
ja das hängt davon ab wie der warenkorb
ist also es geht ja immer nur ums
prozentual nicht um absolute die
reichsten werden insofern am stärksten
betroffen weil sie am meisten
konsumieren das ist ja nicht gemeint
nicht prozentual es kann schon sein dass
die güter des täglichen bedarfs die
dringend notwendig sind stärker
inflationieren das tun sie in der
tendenz mittelfristig sowieso
und jetzt vielleicht auch unter den
neuen verhältnissen aber ich kann keine
präzise aussage dazu mal das muss ich
erst mal prüfen
wenn wir uns das anschauen ja gerne wir
haben schon mal ganz kurz vorher
darüber gesprochen wenn wir dieses
tarifjahr uns anschauen und der eine
oder andere tatsächlich die inflation
spürt und sagt ich brauche aber dann
auch wirklich mehr geld im portemonnaie
die gewerkschaften sich da auch schon
stückweit munitionieren wie groß ist
denn da die gefahr dass wir da in eine
lohn preis spirale geraten wenn die
gewerkschaften entsprechend hohe
forderungen stellen also ich habe den
eindruck dass es dann auch bei den
gewerkschaften
eine hohe sensibilität gibt und
natürlich wären gewerkschaften für
höhere löhne streiken alles andere wäre
wäre wäre überraschend aber ich hab' ich
habe den eindruck dass auch den
gewerkschaften in deutschland da die das
problem sehr bewusst ist und ich habe
momentan von denen bastian forderungen
sehe wir haben ja dieses jahr vor allem
in der zweiten jahreshälfte eine ganze
reihe von tarifabschlüssen in großen
branchen die anstehen da wird man das
genauer wissen aber das was ich momentan
höre und sehe scheint mir doch von einer
großen verantwortung geprägt zu sein
das werden wir sehen also ich meine ich
bin ja nur ein bisschen älter das hat
den vorteil dass ich die 70er jahre ganz
gut überblicken
damals hatte ich gerade mein studium
abgeschlossen war junger assistent und
dann waren diese ölkrisen damals da war
es dann so dass die gewerkschaften sehr
wohl zugelegt haben aber sie haben
natürlich erst mal gewartet wie das ist
mit der inflation und die
lohnforderungen kamen ungefähr ein jahr
später nachdem preissteigerungen also
nicht demselben ja sagen ja einige leute
wir haben keine lust nur ein preis
spirale wald werde im letzten jahr noch
keine inflations zulage gefordert hat
das ist ja absurd das argument die
wussten ja noch gar nicht dass inflation
da ist aber jetzt im herbst werden die
alle wissen wie hoch die inflation war
die zahlen liegen auf dem tisch und eine
gewerkschaft die das denn nicht ein
fordert diese 5,4 prozent die jetzt
schon da sind und es werden noch mehr
bis dahin
die würde ja ihre mitglieder nicht
richtig vertreten also davon können wir
für meine person mit sicherheit ausgehen
das ist diesen preis spirale gibt dessen
selbst verstärker
dabei dann auch der mindestlohn der sich
auf siegerin fest lohn ist um 25 prozent
gegenüber dem was noch letztes jahr galt
jetzt
erhöht worden oder soll erhöht werden
das ist für sich genommen nicht so wild
weil nicht so viele betroffen sind aber
dann kommen die lohn abstände die
nächsten die eine lohn stufe drüber sind
über den mindestlohn sagen
jetzt kriege ich ja kaum mehr als ihr
das geht nicht wir wollen auch mehr und
die dritten wollen auch mehr also die
ganze skala wird von unten her
hochgeschoben und alle löhne werden sich
dadurch erhöhen es gibt also auch noch
mal einen kostenschub für die
unternehmen der hinzu tritt also wir
haben perspektivisch die verteuerung
durch den mix aus brauner und grüner
energie den wir jetzt haben wir haben
diesen beschluss wir haben dann neue
verschuldungs wünsche in der neuen
regierung weil die fdp sagt steuerung
gibt es mit uns nicht und die grünen und
die spd sagt wir wollen aber geld für
dieses und jenes alles gut begründet
also einigt man sich auf die
verschuldungs hatten wir übrigens vor 50
jahren auch schon als die sozial
liberale koalition war daher hat die fdp
gesagt steuererhöhungen gibt es mit uns
nicht die spd wollte geld das war die
zeit wo man die freibäder überall
gemacht hat schlüsselzuweisungen an die
gemeinden gegeben wurde man hat aber
kein geld man hat sich verschuldet und
diese verschuldung in der zeit wo
sowieso die energiepreise teurer wurden
heizte das ganze nochmal an nicht und
hatte konjunkturell leider keine guten
wirkungen helmut schmidt hat damals
gesagt dass es mir lieber ich habe fünf
prozent inflation als fünf prozent
arbeitslosigkeit in wahrheit hat er dann
fünf prozent inflation im durchschnitt
dieses jahrzehnt und die
arbeitslosigkeit war zum schluss um eine
million höher als zu beginn des
jahrzehnts er hat also beides gekriegt
eine inflation und arbeitslosigkeit man
kann in der zeit der inflation einfach
keine schulden machen das geht nicht der
staat muss sich jetzt zurücknehmen und
bremsen das ist die grundrezept uhr des
keynesianismus
in der rezession wenn es an nachfrage
fehlt darf man sich verschulden um gast
zu geben aber im boom wenn es eine
überschuss nachfrage ist muss genau das
gegenteil passieren und dazu ist aber
nie die bereitschaft in der politik
vorhanden der kellner wenn wir dabei der
ausgabenseite mit der staatsfinanzen
gerade sind der umbau der deutschen
wirtschaft wird geld kosten das wird die
wirtschaft zum teil selber tragen aber
es soll auch mit steuergeld unterstützt
werden die grünen wollen
wollten das nun als erstes das ist in
den koalitionsverhandlungen und nicht so
umgesetzt worden wie sie sich das
vorgestellt haben herr lindner widmen
und 60 milliarden kronen haushaltsmittel
um heiligt der zweck die mittel
dass wir das wir sowohl aus kohle wir
haben ja gerade gesagt dass mir auch die
unterschiede zu den 70er jahren nicht
also wir haben einen teil der inflation
ist getrieben durch die
verkehrsproblematik was wir vorher
besprochen hatten einen teil der
inflation
ist
ist getrieben durch durch die globale
entwicklung am
energiemarkt ein teil der inflation ist
getrieben durch die durch die
sondereffekte mehrwertsteuerabsenkung
jetzt wieder erhöhen also macht paar
effekte mit drin in der inflation die
jetzt als wir an diese fonds aber jetzt
schon vorbei genau das vocal naja die
das wird mir jetzt dieses jahr sehen
dass dieser google rausgeht und dadurch
natürlich auch wenn er mit einer
niedrigeren inflation erst mal
also weniger als die jetzt 4,9 prozent
die wir im januar hatten
rechnen können so das wird man weiter
betrachten müssen und dann ist es aber
so dass sie zu recht sagen
wir wollen wir wollen investieren dass
sich halt anders wir haben riesige
aufgaben unserem land das eine ist eine
co2 freie wirtschaft zu erreichen das
ist innerhalb der infrastruktur
anders als den 70er jahren
aktuell zahlen zahlt der staat faktisch
keine zinsen auf diese kredite auf diese
schulden die ja oft und auch das ist ja
im punkt und welchen nutzen wir um werte
zu schaffen also eine nachhaltige
infrastruktur ist ja auch ein wert für
uns und für künftige generationen eine
klimafreundliche wirtschaft ist ein wert
für uns und für künftige generationen
die wir schaffen und dafür braucht es
natürlich auch investitionen
investitionen in unternehmen ich sehe
ganz viele unternehmen sei es in der
stahlbranche die sich aufmachen wollen
in unter dem schlagwort grün stahl
beispielsweise und da ist es in der tat
sondern geht es innerhalb der
europäischen union wettbewerb so zu
organisieren dass das diese
stahlindustrie in europa die es da auf
den weg macht nicht in einem in allen
unfairen wettbewerb mit anderen globalen
akteuren sei es in china oder sei es in
usa oder sonst wo getrieben wird und
deswegen reden wir gerade jetzt in
diesem ersten halbjahr auch über die
frage von sogenannten co2 grenze
ausgleich so dass das in der produktion
mit berücksichtigt wird also dass ein
träger stahl und grüner star im zoo
regime miteinander verglichen wird und
da ein 1 1 gleiches spielfeld
hergestellt wird das ist sehr technisch
und ist kompliziert aber das ist ein
bestreben auch gemeinsam der
europäischen union um eine veränderung
zu erreichen das ist total wichtig und
daran arbeiten wir ja dann ist da noch
mal kurz darauf eingehen darf das ist
nicht falsch mit dem grenze ausgleich
aber es ist nicht die lösung
warum nicht weil der haupteffekt läuft
ja nicht dadurch dass andere erdteile
jetzt industrieproduktion von uns
übernehmen
sondern darüber dass andere erteile
die brennstoffe übernehmen die wir jetzt
nicht mehr kaufen das ist ein ganz
unmittelbarer direkter fast trivialer
effekt der immer übersehen wird selbst
wenn es überhaupt keinen import von
industriewaren aus anderen ländern gäbe
wäre es ja immer noch so dass die
brennstoffe die wir europäer aus
umweltgründen und wohlerworbenen gründen
nicht mehr in die luft nicht verbrennen
wollen und in die luft pusten wollen
dass die von den tankern und den öl und
den pipelines anderswohin gelenkt werden
und dort verbrannt werden die sind ja
nicht weg die bleiben ja nicht in der
erde das problem ist dass wir letztlich
erreichen müsste nur hier in einen
mechanismus dass das öl und das gas
wirklich in der erde bleibt und gar
nicht was rauskommt das können wir aber
nicht erreichen weil wir keine kontrolle
über die
anbieter haben die ölscheichs haben wir
nicht im griff die putin mit seinen alle
gleich nahm wir nicht im griff die
verkaufen das eben anderswo und alles
was rauskommt aus der erde geht auch in
die luft wenn ich nicht weiß wie schwer
tun das einfach woanders hin china will
da schon längst immer wieder neue reihe
science nach china gewehr aber wenn sie
da mal die
die anschauen wie wir dahin schaffen
könnte ist es noch sehr gering und was
wir sagen wir haben wir eine eigene
verantwortung in deutschland hatten viel
größeren pro kopf co2 ausstoß so viele
also viel stärker als die meisten
anderen europäischen ländern auch im
globalen maßstab das heißt wir haben
schöne verantwortung zu zeigen dass das
gelingt und es reichte nicht nur auf die
anderen zu zeigen sondern wir wollen
vorangehen wir wollen zeigen dass es
möglich ist eine co2 freie wirtschaft
und das
wenn derselbe brennstoff den wir jetzt
einsparen von den anderen verbraucht wir
müssen zusammen wir müssen nur insgesamt
globalen rückgang wieder reicht ist doch
dann nicht der fall wenn ich wenn wir
zeigen das ist möglich sind wir am ende
das müssen wir führen diesen streit
ist ja auch nicht uninteressant trotzdem
würde ich gerne noch eine schluss frage
stellen und zwar
sehen in dieser lassen sich denn die
kostenintensiven aufgaben der
zukunftspolitik gegen den klimawandel
mit den zwängen für
stabilitätsorientierte gegenwart politik
vereinbaren geht das über wie sie lassen
sich sehr wohl vereinbaren also ich sag
mal ganz ketzerisch die jetzt
im arbeitsleben des lebens stehende
generation ja denn geht es doch im
vergleich zu früheren generationen recht
gut
erstens haben sie wenig kinder die sie
ernähren müssen ja die sind einfach
nicht da an kosten noch kein geld und
keine ressourcen und keine zeit ja und
zweitens haben sie noch viele eltern die
sie haben sie noch viele geschwister die
in der lage sind die finanzierung der
eltern mit zu tragen denn die generation
der eltern hatte ja noch viele kinder
das heißt wer jetzt im arbeitsleben
steht hat relativ wenig rentenlasten
und hat wenig kinder lasten also es geht
den leuten wirklich gut geht wie gut
genug das ist schon klar aber im
historischen vergleich ist das einfach
so und insofern kann man also der
jetzigen gesellschaft sehr wohl eine
konsum einschränkung zu suchen um eben
für die zukunft für zukünftige
generation noch ein bisschen was übrig
zu lassen und deswegen darf man sich
auch nicht verschulden mit der bitte um
eine kurze anfrage ich komme dieser
ökonomischen betrachtungsweise von
kindern sehr sehr schwer klar aber als
rein erkundungs betrachten aber
geschenke seine große freude kinder zu
haben das wird es mir mich und
aber ich würde sagen ja es ist möglich
und dass deswegen wollen wir auch haben
wir gesagt wir wollen in die regierung
gewandt zeigen dass es geht und wir wir
kämpfen und wir streiten die nächsten
vier jahre ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für diese angeregte diskussion
und ich bedanke mich bei ihnen fürs
zuschauen morgen um 22.15 sehen sie hier
an dieser stelle die phoenix runde und
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend bei phoenix
[Musik]